élément nouveau de ces conflits sociaux
la contagion à l'école la fsu et la fen
la fédération de l'éducation nationale
appellent en effet à la grève les
enseignants de la maternelle au lycée à
une grève nationale reconductible à
partir de demain un certain nombre
d'instituteurs ont débrayé dès
aujourd'hui notamment à paris ce qui n'a
pas contribué à simplifier la vie
quotidienne les parents d'élèves
reportage son talent qui ne remet un
débat sur channel à la grève 200
instituteurs en grève sur six ans dans
un arrondissement de paris dès demain un
tiers des enseignants c'est à peu près
le chiffre de la mobilisation sur la
france la grève est intersyndicale pour
la protection sociale contre la réforme
de la sécurité sociale fois qu'on aura
obtenu le retrait du plan juppé
on n'aura pas réglé pour autant le
problème de la protection sociale
retraite pension emploi salaires c'est
l'école aussi coup défend plus
généralement plus menaçants des services
publics qui se précisent un petit peu
plus tous les jours on doit la sntr on
le voit avec la poste on la vit déjà
depuis longtemps et on le veut
c'est avec la famille mais si au 77 rue
parisienne on a voté la grève
juste en face aux 71 ont la reporte un
jeudi
parce que demain on ne souhaite pas trop
ennuyer les parents n'a pas pu les
premiers acceptons et on veut accueillir
les parents à qui ça pose problème
solidarité ou pas avec les familles le
mouvement de grève dans le primaire
s'annonce assez dur et long pour la
plupart des grévistes il n'est pas
question de reprendre les cours
avant lundi prochain